ladies and gentlemen all of my hopes and
dreams have now come true finally for
the first time ever a movie about
Wilford Brimley cosplay Tosh so tusk is
written and directed by Kevin Smith I
guess he came up with the idea for this
movie cuz he saw some Craigslist ad for
this guy looking for a roommate it was
the creepiest [ __ ] you've ever heard he
talked about it on his podcast and now
he's we're gonna make a movie about that
as movie stars Justin Long he's a
podcaster he's pretty much a piece of
[ __ ] human being there are two kinds of
people who do what I do who do YouTube
videos or vlogs and vodcast tolerable
individuals who do it because it's fun
to talk about these subjects then piece
of [ __ ] human being he is that second
one Haley Joel Osment says Cohoes I
haven't seen that dude in a while he
goes to Canada and he runs across his ad
for this old dude who wants to talk
about stories cuz yes he's had an
adventurous life so he goes there he's
talking with this guy he's this total
Vincent Price s guy and you know this
guy's bad news you know he is a spider
in a web and Justin Long should just
leave and if he doesn't things are gonna
go bad for him and he doesn't leave and
at this point the movie I was loving
this movie this is great setup and I was
like oh there's gonna be one of those
movies where Justin Leung is you know
power is taken away from him and this
old guys gonna keep him there against
his will and it's gonna just freak me
out it's a solid thriller he's got going
on with that Kevin Smith dialogue which
actually works for a movie like this
everything was within context everything
was cool and I was loving where this was
going and then it goes the extra mile
and then it straight-up goes and goes
first of all the performances in this
movie I liked it there's not a bad actor
in this movie even the hot chick is good
there's this one scene where it's
zooming into her and she has this
monologue and she's tearing up and she
just does this ominous tone to it I was
like whoa I mean she's like a good actor
Justin Long was really good Haley Joel
Osment was really good actually there's
an inspector I didn't care for I'll get
to him later but that dude you know the
guy who plays that sheriffing from dusk
till dawn [ __ ] plugged in the back of
the head that gas station yeah he's in
this movie he was awesome this is the
creepiest dude ever these guys just
unsettling he puts a vibe out there this
guy rambles on like old dudes do but
it's almost Tarantino ask you're liking
it I'm engaged oh [ __ ] I shouldn't be
because Justin Long's engaged oh damn
I'm him right now but ultimately this
movie goes from really solid creepy
setup to the point where you're like oh
I'm still creeped out and Oly [ __ ] I
don't want to be here but I like
watching it because it's just it's
hitting me at my heart then it goes the
extra mile to where you're like uh
unbelievable grade-b horror movie
nonsense granted it's disturbing imagery
that you see and it is unsettling but
then you realize Smith is just going for
shock value and the girl in this movie
actually has a pretty good line she's
telling Justin long she says something
like shocking isn't funny what she
should have told Kevin Smith I mean
granted the phrase should have been
shocking isn't entertaining and shocking
is funny to some and shocking is
entertaining to others I just found it
ironic that in the movie you have the
girl telling Justin long who clearly has
the character flaw she's like shocking
isn't funny Kevin Smith is like yeah but
shocking was entertaining and he made
this movie I can't help but touch on
irony like that and that appointment
this movie had such good build-up and
traded it in just for shock value if you
like the movie shot its own foot off and
like no no we're just gonna go to easy
routes like damn it Kevin Smith you
could have had an awesome movie you were
going there I stopped then when this
movie starts going for full shock value
it trades in it's creepy vibe and it's
build-up and it's subtle comedic
undertones that work well with it with
completely separate tones that clash and
don't really work well together the
tonal shifts in this movie didn't always
work it does have some good dialogue
some of the dialogue drags on the funny
scenes weren't so funny yeah you know
you chuckle in a couple of them but for
the most part you just said no like I
think he was trying to be funny and the
comedies he Clips by the disturbing
imagery [ __ ] that he was going for also
so on that as a comedy it's not that
successful like there's this one
character in the movie this dude is
straight-up Inspector Clouseau from the
Pink Panther and up until this point the
movies actually establish itself as to
what it's trying to be which is a horror
movie
and then this cartoon detective
Inspector Clouseau comes on you're like
all right are we going for his straight
up comedy now because it's not that
funny and the guy rambles on and on and
on and when he's telling the story he's
not like creepy Vincent Price guy this
dude's just he's an actor that Kevin
Smith was afraid to yell cut on he would
monologue and you're like alright I'm
checking out I'm checking my watch if I
could pull out my phone and check my
tweets in the movie theatre without
being a dick I would do that right now
not only were his monologues not that
interesting he himself didn't fit in the
movie in the end you can argue that tusk
did what it was going for which is it's
trying to disturb you did it go for that
yeah did it succeed in that yeah does it
make it a good movie not really
example those Twilight movies were made
to be movies that snared tweens in the
movie theaters did they succeed yeah are
they good no Phantom Menace was made to
be a kids movie that appealed to kids
did it succeed yes is it good I don't
think so just because a movie did what
it set out to do doesn't make it a good
movie I mean
I could watch someone get sodomized with
a chainsaw that will stick with me does
it make it good no to the fact that tusk
does stick with you after the movie
theater and you're thinking about it
you're like oh that did actually create
me out in parts even dare I say disturb
me doesn't change the fact that I had
like three different vibes that was
going for none of it really mixed the
performances were solid for sure it was
a great suspense horror movie for the
first third of it after that it dropped
off into unbelievable shock value
nonsense and I just don't dig that this
movies like misery meets human centipede
with no ass to mouth there you go to us
this is kind of movie that like you're
gore fiend friend would love I have a
friend he's a huge Gore fiend he loves
those great be disturbing horror movies
that don't make any sense yeah Justin
how you doing buddy I'm talking about
you like we were out camping he was like
oh you got to see this movies like this
and he starts listing off this great be
nonsense and I was like is it good
there's like well no but it's really
[ __ ] up this is his kind of movie he
get it on DVD blu-ray get the digital
copy for good measure in the end I will
say tusk would probably be a good time
if you're drunk yeah and now it's a oh I
drank the tea don't drink the tea never
drink the tea all right so what's the
creepiest suspense thriller horror movie
for you whatever it is comment below let
me know our viewer Kevin Smith fanboy
and you just want to get the nails on
the cross writing just crucify me yeah
this is a comment section it's what is
there for guys this is YouTube after all
and as always if you like what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
you